we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
very important question about non-voters
non-voters take a listen to this hey
David I was wondering with all the
Democratic candidates out right now if
your personal candidate doesn't get
taped is there a certain number of
people that will just refuse to vote for
the Democrat because their candidate
isn't the nominee or is everyone just
gonna vote for the Democrat cuz I heard
there was a lot of issues last year
where there were a lot of people who
were Bernie supporters who were spurred
that you didn't get the nomination and
decided not to vote for Hillary Clinton
so listen I don't know the answer to
that but it's something I am afraid of
and we it is so important right now that
we take step one and starting to repair
this country and it is only step one
which is the removal of Donald Trump
earlier on today's program and on other
programs
I've talked extensively about the damage
done by Trump will extend far beyond his
presidency the Republican Party isn't
fixed when Trump leaves because the
Republican Party is what allowed from to
become their nominee and ultimately to
become the president
so when Trump leaves the Republican
Party is still an absolutely abortive
attempt at being a reasonable political
party so we need to remove Trump a step
one and unfortunately it is conceivable
that if someone really likes one
candidate and that candidate is not the
nominee that some of them will stay home
that or some might vote for Trump
although I hope it's a very small number
as close to zero as possible some may go
third party some may write in I think
that that's extremely problematic now if
you're in a truly safe state I
understand that your calculation may be
different
strictly speaking I think that the right
way to approach this is assume the
election could be close no matter where
you're voting I get that in
Massachusetts the Democrat is going to
defeat Donald Trump and so if I vote
third party or write some
don't vote it's not going to make a
difference but the problem with that
logic is if everyone who has that
thought occurred to them it takes the
action that does change things so I
think it's logically fallacious to fall
into that lack of thinking we should all
just vote as if the election did depend
on our vote in terms of whether people
might just stay home because their
candidate isn't there my hope is that
people who don't like Donald Trump would
realize that any of the Democratic
options right now is better than Trump
and that thus they would vote so I could
understand people who are in the bernie
warren wing if Joe Biden is the nominee
saying I'm not voting for Biden Biden
said as we covered today that you know
marijuana is a gateway drug
Biden's not for serious reform to the
health insurance system I'm not going to
vote for him what Trump is worse and I
think at this point we have seen that
the let Trump win to break it all down
and then we'll rebuild it mentality I
mean it just hasn't worked it did it
didn't play out it's not surprising that
it didn't play out that way I think that
is very dangerous thinking so we'll have
time to talk more about this I do
believe that we need to start seriously
talking about the reality that everybody
should participate if turnout favors
them they win easily even with low Trump
approval because of the electoral
college system that we have particularly
if our sides turnout is depressed in
those key swing and battleground states
so I am very worried about it I don't
want to be hyperbolic or alarmist but
mathematically in those states where
it's close
some Democrats saying I'm not voting
because my guy or gal is not the nominee
could turn some states for Trump and it
could turn the election for Trump we
don't want to let that happen we'll talk
about it more we have a great bonus show
for you today we will talk about
cheating allegations against the Houston
Astros that have the baseball world
demanding punishment and we're going to
talk about cheating in sports more
generally mi t--'s ai scores the egotism
of drivers to try to make a
autonomous vehicles more assertive if
they assess that drivers around them are
driving in a particular way it's very
interesting and it relates to some of
the complex math that goes into
programming autonomous vehicles and
number three we've talked about the
Starbucks open bathroom policy in the
context of race-based discrimination
that we've seen at some Starbucks stores
in the last couple of years there have
been some stories about that there's a
very interesting new study which says
that on the one hand the open bathroom
policy does some good things for
Starbucks on the other hand that it
seems to be hurting foot traffic and as
many of you know I've not been to a
Starbucks for 15 years so hopefully
producer Pat will be able to inform me
on exactly what it is that is going on
at Starbucks these days all of the
stories and more on today's bonus show
become a member at join pakman.com to
get instant access or become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show at
the $5 or greater level that will also
give you access to the bonus show